so the hour of nine o'clock having
arrived I'm going to open this meeting
of the joint legislative performance
audit oversight committee and
um because it is the Senate's turn to
reside
and because I am apparently the longest
serving continuous member on the
committee I have been asked if I will
open the meeting and the first order of
business that we have is to elect a
chair from the Senate who will serve for
the next two years so with that I'm
going to throw open nominations from the
floor
I'll nominate Senator Rosenwald that
much
are there any further nominations
seeing none uh I would entertain a
motion that the nominations be closed
when we cast one ballot
is there a second
all in favor
aye
opposed
congratulations Senator Rosenwald
um this is my first time on this
committee
so
um it will be a learning process but I
think and we have an agenda and I see
that our first order of business is
acceptance of the November 10th meeting
minutes lots of us were not on the
committee then
however because it's a new legislature
we can all vote on the minutes we don't
have to abstain so has everybody had a
chance to read the minutes
I would move acceptance of the minutes
even though I wasn't actually at that
last meeting a second and I was at that
last meeting okay is there any
correction
needed to them or discussion
well then all in favor of accepting the
minutes as presented please say aye aye
and he opposed
new minutes are adopted thank you
um discussion of performance auditing
for new members
sure we'll take it from here thank you
congratulations and could you introduce
yourself sure for the record I'm Steve
Smith the director of audits for the LBA
and joining me here is uh Jay Henry he's
our performance audit supervisor
so given that we have several new
members we thought we'd just take a few
minutes and just Jay's going to kind of
do an orientation for you he's already
provided some handouts when we emailed
the agenda Etc some of the statutes that
govern the committee and performance
auditing but Jay will kind of walk just
to give you kind of a general
30 000 foot level view of what we do
when it comes to performance audit but
also in particular what the committee
some considerations the committee should
take when they're evaluating and looking
at topics so great so with that Jay
good morning good morning good morning
as you may know the LBA has two
divisions the budget division the audit
division budget division helps the
legislature with the budget and the
audit division we do performance Audits
and financial audits
this committee decides the topics that
we're going to audit for performance
audits
audits evaluate past performances and
provides information recommendations to
improve government operations for
leaders of the agencies and the
legislature
audits help to provide transparency of
government operations
the legislature has given the LBA
authority to access all types of program
information including confidential
information when it's directly related
to our audit topics
we are basically able to look under the
hood of programs to see how things are
running
well we become knowledgeable about these
topics we are not experts in the topics
we are our value comes into knowing how
programs any government program should
be run and understanding the internal
controls that agencies should have in
place
government auditing standards which we
follow provides a framework for
performing high quality work with
competency Integrity
objectivity and Independence
government auditing standards require us
to consider fraud in every audit and be
aware of it and think about where is it
likely to happen and even though it may
not be the focus of an audit it's
something we have to consider
standards require that we review at
least elements of our program's internal
control system
these this includes the controlled
environment risk assessment control
activities information and communication
and monitoring
internal control is a process affected
by the agency's management that will
provide a reasonable assurance that
objectives of the entity will be
achieved
performance audits take time and
resources it's not like a reporter just
simply asking questions
we have to follow the government
auditing standards we research the
topics the industry that that's being
that the agency
is is in
we research relevant laws rules policies
procedures and guidelines we seek input
from the agency officials staff of the
program
users or recipients of the program and
other stakeholders through interviews or
surveys
we test the accuracy of program data
when we need to we conduct file reviews
and we also try to write useful reports
for the audit and for legislative
oversight
there's nothing in statute that requires
an agency takes any actions on our
recommendations
however there are executive orders that
require the agencies report to
transparency New Hampshire updates on
the audits that they've on the
how they fulfilled the uh the um
their uh recommendation our
recommendations
now you have two things that are
important for this uh for this agency to
for this committee to do and one is to
um determine if the topic is suitable
for a performance audit
as prior members of the committee can
tell you they spend a lot of time
looking at a topic and deciding is this
worthy of a performance audit or is this
just a research question uh that you
know Senate research or house research
could answer if you have us do it it can
become very costly because of all the
things we have to do around it
um the other uh issue the other thing
you have to do is to decide what the
scope of the audit is going to be
now the scope of the audit defines the
extents and boundaries of what the
Auditors are going to examine
uh the number of elements go into this
including the question that you ask the
type of performance audit that you want
when the legislature wants the
information
the availability of audit resources
what time period will be audited
do we need to sample do any samples that
are statistically valid
do we have access to complete and
accurate data
the size and complexity of the program
and the need to compare to other other
states programs around the country
the scope and the number of weaknesses
we uncover determine the size of our
reports and the time it takes to
complete
the size can also affect The Oddities
ability to deal with what we give them
recently we've had three audits that
have been over 300 pages one of them was
had 60 observations
where we looked at the entire agency
on the other end we've had audits that
just looked at the the medical cannabis
ID card and why it was taking so long to
be issued that ended up being a 30-page
report with a nine observations
now the
the Cannabis report only took a thousand
hours
the Wetland Bureau took 11 000 hours
so the scope of the audit
you know is important to how much work
we do and how much time and resources we
put into it
so I'd just say keep that in mind
you know when you make your decisions
I think that's about it I don't know if
you have any other questions do you have
the handle questions nope you're good
okay
do we all know each other in this room
well you do and I do but we do have new
people so let's introduce ourselves
starting with the senator from district
one Carrie gendro from district one and
district one I don't know if this would
be helpful or not but it encompasses 58
towns about 2500 square miles and it's
in Northern New Hampshire
so
Lucy Weber from the house I represent
currently sorry and Walpole but I have
at various times represented 13
different Jefferson County towns and
[Music]
um
I serve on Health and Human Services in
the house if that's helpful
represent Senate District 15 which
includes Concord Beau and Hopkinton I
used to represent Henniker and Warner
but my district has changed a little bit
in the senate i serve on Health and
Human Services and the Judiciary
Committee
good morning Howard Pearl I'm Senate
District 17 which is basically east of
Concord from Nottingham to Northfield
covering 12 towns I chaired Edna in the
house excuse me in the Senate and also
serve as Vice chair on energy and
natural resources and finance as well
good good to see my fellow house members
again I haven't seen in a while so I
served three terms in the house prior to
this it's good to be back see you all
great Cindy Rosenwald from District 13
in this Senate it's most of Nashua
representative Ken Wilder I'm a chairman
of the house finance committee been on
that for many years
I'm from Rockingham County
District 13.
I'm Jerry Griffin I represent uh mon
Vernon lineborough and New Boston
I serve on division one of finance and
on the full Finance
and I'm an alternate on fiscal
I Representative Keith Earth I serve
where
Vice chair of the finance committee
second division three
and also a member of the fiscal
committee
Senator Tim Lang District 2 goes from
exit 29 East side of 93 Exit 29 all the
way to the east side of 93 from exit 20.
I am the chairman of the Senate Ways and
Means Committee the vice chair of Joe
Carr and I serve on education as well
thank you
so any questions for Mr Henry or Mr
Smith
I have a I have a couple one um I mean
so you told us it couldn't range from a
thousand hours
to 11
000 hours how many
performance audits can you do a year
or do you do a year
it really depends on the size of those
audits
um we have right now I think we have
three teams three audit teams that are
working we we have a new hire coming on
and I think July June
um so we've had a little we've had
trouble hiring uh it's been very slow
process taking many many months that
affects how many people are on the jobs
that we like to have at least one in
charge auditor and two staff we've been
doing some audits with just two people
um we're going to be starting one audit
right now with just one person uh who's
going to end up having using a financial
auditor for a few months as a staff so
you know we're able to to share some
resources uh between the financial and
performance side and occasionally we
also help the budget side during the
budget process I don't think we did it
this year but in past years they've
taken some of our people
because that's where you know it's
really needed there so so about how many
um I've been doing this year past year
we do two
or three it's it's funny because they
could we had two giant reports that came
up two two of those 300 uh page reports
that came out on the same day and so not
you know we had a very slow year the
year before and then we ended up with
three two of those plus another one so
yeah again it's the size of the reports
if we're lucky a fast report is six
months one of those that like that
thousand hour unless we again if we put
everyone on the audit
yeah so it's a balancing act of what
resources we have and and what audits we
have to do
so I guess we'll have to keep that in
mind
um can we request Financial audits or
just performance audits
yes
yes the committee's responsibilities
just performance audits I mean certainly
um either through through my cane or
myself
um if if
we we determine where we go on the
financial side but certainly where we
take input you know if there are areas
of concern things of that nature
um we can factor that into our
rotation we try to
depending upon the
findings that we have that I'm speaking
to the financial side now
we have a lot of material weaknesses
significant deficiencies that we that we
uncover in one audit then chances are in
a few within five years we like to go
back to follow up with those
however if there weren't a lot of
significant issues then we may not go
back for 10 years
so and there are there are some we do
every year to support the State
financial audit and we also we also have
staff that support the single audit as
well so there's a lot of
so we
our busy season is August through the
December because a lot of the staff is
supporting to keep
um
uh professional accounting fees low as
well as give our staff the experience of
working with a national office and
things but like The Liquor Commission
Lottery Commission we we have been doing
those every year so um okay so only
performance Audits and finally for for
people who are not on fiscal could you
explain what happens when uh recommended
performance audit
is presented to the fiscal penny
sure when this committee let me go back
to the beginning when this committee
charges us with a topic they would like
like us to look at look like the first
one like excuse me weatherization
we uh we will draft a letter for the
chair to sign and that will go to fiscal
fiscal ultimately has to prove the topic
and once fiscal approves the topic then
it officially goes into our queue
and then we begin the process of scoping
it out based on our understanding of
what the committee has charged us with
and then we will come back to you with a
scope statement which we have one today
for you to approve which kind of
outlines what we plan to do we want to
make sure that that's in line with what
the committee wanted us to do
and that begins the audit and then
typically other than a quick status if
if we have a meeting we we will provide
that but once the audit is complete and
we will present it to the fiscal
committee
um
and there will be agency Representatives
or Oddity representatives there to
respond to questions or respond to the
audit
so once um all of our work is non-public
it's confidential until such time is it
that the fiscal committee approves
accepts and approves
the report for release to the public so
up until that time it's it's closely
held it's not public information
in order for the fiscal committee to not
approve a performance audit it has to be
a unanimous vote I believe so
committee so there are 10 members on
fiscal
if one of them or even nine of them
don't want to do an audit
still gets done because it would have to
be all 10 members of fiscal
saying no
rep Weber and just
just to make it clear we don't see it
until after fiscal has accepted it too
right we don't we don't get we don't get
first grabbies no representative Weiler
has this wonderful statement about it's
like Roundup Usual Suspects
you know if I heard what is it
I move that we accept the report place
it on file and release it in the usual
event there you go Senator Roswell I
have a question yeah thank you
um I'm curious about how is there an
opportunity for the public to have input
about requesting certain audits do you
take those requests and then bring them
to us or is that's just something that
the public knows to bring to us if if we
are contacted directly then we will and
we believe it's a performance audit type
of a topic then we will forward that to
the committee for for your consideration
but certainly we prefer that in some
cases amongst the legislature that you
go through this committee through your
peers
um
so it's a combination of both but we
very rarely get someone contacting us
directly
but most of our topics I Believe come
from
you know build members legislature but
we probably hear
from kid institution yes yeah
occasionally we'll get a member that
will contact contact us directly
um a House member or Senator and we'll
forward them to this this committee and
in fact most of our topics will come
from from from you and you may hear it
from you know people in your you know
your voters and your people in your
districts or other members we also
present audits when asked to at other at
policy committees so we've done that in
the past
yes
and I would just add that uh in the
house at least we in the past I haven't
seen so many recently but in the past we
used to get several bills every year
requesting performance Audits and uh
when they came to a committee on which I
sat I always used to say gee we got this
other committee you could go there and
it could be put in line next time we
meet rather than waiting to pass a
statute and it just makes more sense
because this is the place where people
uh balance out the priorities for uh you
know you may have one very good idea but
there may be two or three more exigent
ones in front of us I'm remembering at
one point where we had a very emergency
audit of the veterans home oh yes uh I
remember because there were a number of
concerns raised from a number of
different directions and we felt that
that suddenly should leap ahead of many
of the things that were sitting before
it
yeah I mean this committee gets to
decide or you can tell us what which
audits you want first and you can also
you'll notice some some tabled audits
topics yes you get you can look at those
again you can decide if you want to keep
them table to put them in the put you
know or act on them and go forward or
take them off the table and and you know
suspend them or get all right not
suspend but basically delete them from
the table how generally how often does
this committee meet in a year
I'm gonna say about five times it's when
we need you really or when you or when
you want that's great yeah or You have
topics and you want to attack monthly no
no
it's at the call of the chair okay but
usually we will reach out when we need
the committee for a meeting but I'd say
last few years maybe three four times
right here okay any other questions
about the process and a referral morning
thank you so you have I see you have
four that are tabled for uh on the
topics do you currently have any artists
that you're working on right now that
will be the next section the status of
ongoing audits he was a good move to go
right in Segway Segway any other
questions about process
all right so please tell us about the
ones that are you're working on sure
so the weatherization assistance program
we've completed that and that was
representative fiscal last last month
you all should have received copies as
well as a link to the electronic version
of that
the next one we're actually working on
is the mental health Workforce
requirements we're wrapping up our field
work on that
and we're about to begin observation and
Report drafting
um
one thing to keep in mind is that this
particular audit encompasses five
individual boards and they only meet
once a month
so
um
as we
as we go through the summer
our goal is to get a draft report to all
the boards by June but it's going to
take at least a couple of months for
them to
process it act on it respond things of
that nature so I think we're looking at
maybe uh at the earliest a fiscal
presentation in September for this
particular audit okay
the next one special education dispute
resolution process uh we've completed
field work on that we're now actively or
in report and observation writing
um we hope to have a draft of that to
the department in late June July time
frame
the next one is the state oversight of
special education uh in a few minutes
you will consider the scope statement on
that one so that is the where we are
with that
and uh
the next one Commission on human rights
we just began that we're actually in
communication with the director there to
try to schedule an entrance meeting so
we're just just beginning with that one
and the other topic just to make the
committee aware
um
and as are as uh representative Weber
mentioned here's a situation where we
have a performance audit that was
dictated in statute so HP 1135 related
to the educational Freedom account that
doesn't become effective until October
1st 2023 so they basically the statue
wants a performance audit done but not
sometime after October 1st 2023 so
that's in our queue but not until later
so just to make the committee aware of
that
so unless you have any questions on
those
what I'd like to do is move to the scope
statement
I know I'm going to ask the in charge
manager Steve Grady to come up and walk
you through that yes Senator Lane just
real quick on that last item HB 1135
does that mean you're not starting it
until after October 1st that's when
you're going to start though that's
correct we should get it sometime the
following year
um yes thank you depending upon we have
the opportunity to decide where after of
October 1st did
fits into
the schedule
sure yeah we're not gonna we're gonna
it's there as a placeholder for our
scheduling purposes so the earliest that
we're going to begin it will be October
okay if that's the if that's the
direction but certainly the committee
again it's in statute so we have to act
on it but again the committee can
re-prioritize start it until October
correct yes okay it's great
representative Weber
and with the corollary to that be that
we could
at some time prior to October 1st ask
you to start it October 1st is that
is that within our power do we have to
wait until after October 1st to vote on
it at all
that's it the effective date of the step
of the bill is October 1st 20. oh I see
okay so got it so it sounds like we
brought it would have to wait yep thank
you
any other questions before we looked at
the scope
okay okay
so uh Steve grade is in charge and he'll
come up and walk you through the but
also commissioner Elder Blue from
Department of Education is here and I
know that he would like to speak to the
scope statement as well after Steve
watch
good morning for the record I am Steve
Grady I'm the senior performance audit
manager for the LBA audit division I end
the in charge for special education
performance audit I can proceed through
the details of the scope statement if
you wish if you have any questions we
can also take it up that way it is your
discretion
it should be in the
bundle that you were provided
shall I run through it quickly then
in May 2022 the fiscal committee
approved a request from this body to
conduct a performance audit of the
efficiency and effectiveness of the
Department of education's oversight or
the provision of special education
the topic was Broad and also it assumed
that we would subdivide that topic and
we have done that you heard earlier
Steve Smith talking about the dispute
resolution audit which is ongoing now
this is the second this audit we're
talking about now is the second audit
from that request that this committee
made
according to Department data there were
nearly 31 000 special education students
in New Hampshire as of October 2022 over
91 million dollars was budgeted for
special education in state fiscal years
State fiscal year 2022.
federal laws and regulations created a
regulatory framework with broad
objectives and numerous procedural
requirements
the state special education program was
required to comply with them
State also had flexibility to determine
how to comply with procedural
requirements and Achieve expected
results
state laws and rules operationalize
Federal requirements and added to them
the state special education program was
expected to protect special education
students for further education
employment and independent living
local agencies were to provide special
education services to eligible students
consistent with the state's framework
the Board of Education had a governance
and standard setting role
the board was to regularly review and
make recommendations on all Department
programs
it was to advise the department on goals
the board was also to engage in
rulemaking
and evaluate the program
the state advisory committee on the
education of students and children with
disabilities was intended to advise the
commissioner on special education issues
and unmet needs
this committee was also to promote
Communications and cooperations and
cooperation review funding report
annually on the status of special
education and assist with federal
reporting
the department was responsible for
providing General supervision of special
education Statewide as the key control
point for the state federal relationship
the department functioned as a
pass-through entity for federal grants
it made sub grants to local agencies
the department had to oversee Federal
federally funded operations
had to monitor the operations of local
agencies measure and report on program
performance develop and analyze
information on issues and problems
evaluate local agencies risk of
non-compliance and impose additional
conditions upon risky local agencies
when appropriate
identify aberrant performance help
optimize local agency performance and
remediate non-compliance and take
enforcement action when necessary
management was also responsible for
Designing integrated control systems to
help ensure that it achieved expected
results controls can help assure
accountability and Encompass the plans
methods policies and procedures used to
fulfill the Department's purpose and
accomplish goals and objectives
the department monitored federally
established metrics which demonstrated
the state inconsistently met performance
goals and these goals were primarily
procedural compliance or near-term
results oriented
our proposed autoscope is how effective
was the Department's General supervision
of the state's special education program
in producing expected outcomes in state
fiscal year 2022.
we expect to do a lot of work
with this program we expect to review
federal state statute rules policies
procedures practices
we're going to review relevant audits
guidelines and other material
we're going to observe board meetings
and state advisory committee meetings
we're going to obtain perspectives from
stakeholders
we're going to interview Department
staff
we will also examine Department
management controls and other relevant
manners outside the audit period when
they affect program operations during
and after the audit period
we're going to examine board State
advisory committee and other agencies
management controls when they affect the
program
we will not among other things directly
audit local agencies compliance with
state or federal special education
requirements
we anticipate completing this audit and
presenting the final report to the
fiscal committee early in calendar year
2024.
if you have any questions for me at this
point
thank you senator
I have a couple questions if that's okay
but the first one leads to this
statement at the very beginning of the
document the state's special education
programs was expected to prepare special
education students for one further
education two employment and three
independent living is there any
expectation of the day audit will look
into whether these goals are being
achieved yes
great
that's number one um and then an easy
one I don't know if this is relevant or
not to the actual audit but it'd be very
helpful to know how much total span not
right now but in general how much total
spending is done by the local of school
districts or the non-federal grants but
you know with what what schools have in
their budgets basically as a sum across
the state because I think it's
substantially if I'm not mistaken more
way more than what
the state is yeah I believe that the
localities spend the vast majority of
the dollars expended on the state
special education program thank you but
it will be part of what we look at
am I right in thinking this is going to
be one of our larger audits yes so this
is at the 11 000 an hour type yes
hopefully not 11 000 but uh it could I
mean how big a team do you
currently there are two of us decide
full time to the project with a third uh
expected to join us full-time probably
in another four weeks or so so we'll
have a total of three working on it for
the bulk of the not it
thank you madam chair
um so
of course but a special ed has a lot of
federal law attached to it also and
likely a a lot of sort of federal
overview and supervision so I'm
wondering to the extent that you all
will review uh sort of the requirements
and federal law for the Department of
Education and perhaps even look at any
reviews that the federal department of
education has conducted or not conducted
we will
more questions Senator Brown
so I'm just doing some quick math in my
head here if this is a 10 000 hour audit
you only have three people on it you're
like three years before this is done is
am I doing my math correctly it probably
will not be ten thousand hours but the
estimates do you have us taking it
through uh the first quarter of calendar
year 2024 at this point okay thank you
and I'll just add I mean sometimes the
resources we have available affects how
much how deep we can go on any topic and
that's that's sort of a normal part of
the or when we do audits I mean if you
have a big team you can do a lot of work
um and we can dig down really deep other
times you know we have to also think
about
you know if you spend a year on an audit
you know is that that's a long time and
sometimes you don't need to go down to
the you know looking for the penny you
know it's it's the bigger issues are we
can we find early on and it's really
documenting you know the problems there
uh so it's it's Balancing Act of you
know how much time we spend on every
audit I mean if you've let Auditors go
we'd go we could spend a lot of time on
every program every audit
how many people do you have in the audit
division uh for performance audits we
have 10. so it's not huge not huge and
you got three audits so you can do you
know you see why you know it's we're
lucky we get three people on an audit
um sometimes we pull in someone just for
a short time like someone's free for a
month or two and if the audit you know
there may be one part of the audit they
can do
uh I think we're even doing that right
now with a financial auditor oh no you
and I know yeah as I recall having
looked at a lot of audits over the years
most of the observations don't require
legislative action
to fix them
well you're correct yeah some of them
will will suggest the legislature may
wish to consider legislative act or
we'll tell the agency
you know
you could you know do what the law says
or
change the law I mean that that's you
know we're compliant so we're going to
say loss is this you're not doing you're
not doing that you know first easiest
thing is to do it but it also could be
that there's something you know there's
an old law it doesn't make sense it's
also a time for the agency to come
forward to the legislature and say hey
the Auditors found this and we've
purchased it the costly requirement we
don't need to do this as a better way of
doing you know doing that
and we're presented with things that are
really more urgent
and things that are less
urgent when we get the audit reports the
material weaknesses
yeah when you have significant
efficiency you have 40 observations an
agency cannot just do them all at once
they have to we talk about strategic
planning we hope that they take these
audits they bring they think about what
can we do what needs to be done right
away usually it's the law says to do
things you ought to be in compliance and
then you start worrying about being
efficient
and hopefully you're effective all you
know that's that's the important goal
making sure the program is doing what is
supposed to be supposed to be doing
the court and acting within the the law
any other questions for the Auditors
because the Commissioners here I'm sure
he wants to speak to the proposed scope
before we take any action
thank you
commissioner
morning
good morning for the record Frank Ada
blue Commissioner of Education
um so I chose to come and speak to this
scope statement today because I want to
make sure that we achieve the objective
that we have set out relative to this
particular audit some of you who are
around last year remember Senator Reagan
who was a champion of this working very
hard to make sure that this state
and when I say the state I mean all
public entities involved are doing their
um
their best to make sure that we're
serving the needs of some of our most
vulnerable populations in the state aka
some of our students with disabilities
the scoping was driven largely by uh
very concerned and active parents of
students with disabilities who came in
and expressed their concern that the
system was not serving them well
um as Senator Whitley has pointed out
there's a lot of rules particularly
Federal rules around this so there's and
and was already mentioned here this is
the second audit in this particular area
I will let me just talk about that first
one which is around the dispute
resolution and I and I didn't I mean
I've expressed my concerns internally
but I hadn't expressed them to the
committee relative to that scope but
when we scope these audits we need to
make sure we scope it to get to the
underlying problem
and as an example in the dispute
resolution resolution audit
we are working with a population of
transactions so our sampling
of transactions that we're working with
are those uh
interactions between the the school
district generally and the family who is
not satisfied with whatever is happening
there
um that ultimately rise to the level of
reaching a dispute resolution
what is excluded in that process and is
widely known in this in the education
community and the special education
community in particular
is that a school district who generally
is armed with some very capable lawyers
and parents who are generally Pro Se
arguing and advocating for their
children when the school district
perceives that they're going to lose
right they've they've done some things
happened and they won't be successful in
some type of a you know a legal type of
a process they settle
they they result in a mediated
settlement
gets sealed locally never shows up at
the department doesn't show up on any of
the sampling plans and so a lot of
the individuals who are coming to share
their concerns with Senator Reagan and
other legislators
are subject to a process that would not
even fall inside the scope of some of
this audit activity that we do
now I want to turn to the current audit
um and again here I have concerns that
that the scoping of this work may not
get us to the answer that we're looking
for right it will feel good we'll do an
audit we'll look at all kinds of ins and
outs and we're happy to look at all of
our procedures but at the end of the day
we want to answer the relevant question
what's interesting is you raised a
question about the scope of this audit
and again the scope statement indicates
that there's 90 million dollars of funds
that are spent on special education
can I just tell you that that is a gross
Distortion in terms of how much is being
spent by the state and we did ask the
audit team to include a broader scope so
that had context you know when we talk
about 90 million dollars most of those
funds are passed through that are
incorporating
idea funds as well as special education
Aid right it's about seven million
dollars that is retained by the agency
in terms of administration that's 90
million dollars
that what that doesn't include is all of
as you pointed out the local spending
which is over or close to 900 million
dollars right so we're going to audit a
small portion of this what it also
doesn't include is the adequacy the
differentiated aid funds that go into
special education so I'm not sure that
we've completely encapsulated the full
scope of activity relative to this audit
and I think it's a it's an urgent audit
I don't disagree right we've got
families that the system is not serving
well
and so by scoping the audit as it has
been scoped and and we totally
appreciate that the agency is you know
they're Limited in what they can do like
well if you're task to scope an audit
you Scope one that that you can take
care of right but if you're only looking
at a subset of the old the overall thing
are you really answering the question
that was asked to begin with
um
and so
I think as well uh just like the in the
dispute resolution audit in this work
there's a misperception that somehow the
agency is a pass-through entity can
somehow affect I mean we can have a
little bit of influence but can we
affect what's happening on the ground
for families and children in the state
of New Hampshire in the school districts
in terms of what they are what they are
experiencing whether or not goals of
individual education programs are being
achieved whether or not the school is
focused on making sure that those
children can be successful you know our
our enforcement activities sometimes
feel like a paper tiger I have to sign
complaint letters that I get and
oftentimes it's just a procedural defect
right like I mean I can tell you actual
examples you know a student gets an IEP
and they say that they are going to be
receiving in that IEP this is just one
that came up in the last month you know
this student will have an Extended
Learning opportunity in their IEP to get
them some work related experience
well you know what it didn't the student
has been the entire year and we haven't
seen any action on that and the response
from the district is well the IEP
doesn't specify when it has to happen
meaning it could happen on the last week
of school and somehow that's going to be
okay right so you know like we're
sitting here I'm wanting to say like
that's not what the intent was the
intent was to get this child the
experiences
um but sometimes the rules and the
regulations don't allow that type of uh
of lean in in that particular case
that's a federal rule that we can't do
anything about
but I guess what I would I'm coming to
you today just make sure that I I
advocate for a scope of an audit that's
going to answer the Germaine question of
making sure that students with
disabilities are getting the best
possible services that they can and
those are the only comments that I had
I think it's partially a question and
partially comment and I'm seeking to
understand if I'm hearing you correctly
because much of what I was hearing you
say particularly in your introductory
remarks had to do with the cost of
special education and performance audits
are not to do with the cost and they're
not even
necessarily as I understand it and I'm
glad to be corrected to do with
uh efficient use of funds although I
think that comes into it tangentially it
seems to me that what we have here is
an actual what we're looking at as the
scope statement stands now
is
the interaction of
your Department's supervision
with all these Myriad plans and rules
and
um
although I would love to think of a way
of doing that more narrowly I can't and
doesn't look like anybody else has
either but I guess I I would want to
just say
when when you came to your conclusion
which is we want to know we're doing the
best job which is certainly the goal of
all of us uh
I guess I'm not sure that's the goal of
a performance audit because my
understanding is uh that actually
they're intended
to see whether you're doing the job you
were told to do by Statute Rule and
other regulatory things and
than the corollary to that is does it
make sense to do this this way and do we
need to make changes
would you agree with that or have I
gotten that wrong so I I appreciate the
comments but I and I also agree that
this is a performance audit and it's not
a financial audit but the finances
dictate where much of that performance
takes place and so what I would say is
that the way that we've scoped this
audit which carves out a substantive
amount of the performance right so this
audit doesn't include looking at how are
these students being served in our
school systems where the bulk of the
service is being provided knock
yourselves out you can audit away over
here at our 10 percent and some of our
processes influence the school but the
performance by and large takes place in
that local Lea and so even if there was
just a both end like let's look at some
of the school districts let's let's
reach outside of ourselves if that's
where much of the performance is taking
place to see what those interactions
look like to see how those schools are
supporting their students because I
agree with you it's a performance audit
and much of that performance takes place
outside of the scope of the department
and so I just that's my so I think we're
saying we're in vmint agreement relative
to that
representative
no I think it's very important that we
do look at how the the costs are done
because it's the only way you can really
assess this and
you know it's this it's this three and a
half times the average cost per pupil
which is about 75 000 and then it's 20
for the Local District and 80 percent
for the state until we get to 10 times
or roughly 200 000 and then the state
pays the rest of it and I think those
are very important things when you're
looking at the management one that has
always Disturbed me is when the The
Local District says we've spent seventy
thousand and three thousand of that is
this fund
and perhaps another twenty or thirty
thousand was Medicaid we've never been
able everybody hides behind HIPAA
and doesn't give us the true cost of how
much Medicaid fund the local district
has taken credit for that you don't know
you just get this we've spent seventy
thousand give me more and
they maybe they didn't spend seventy
thousand of local funds maybe they just
spent half that and so I think that's an
important aspect that's part of this in
my mind of looking at the scope of this
statement seeing how all the funds are
divided and I hope we can get more
information on HIPAA or not HIPAA but
Medicaid funds because it's always
avoided even if we just had it in total
like special ed includes 100
000 100 million of of Medicaid funds we
ought to know that because we're paying
for that in another place
so I think that's an important part
maybe that's maybe it's more than they
they want to take on the scope but I
think I would like to know it from a
from an aspect of auditing so where's
the real money coming from and it is
like you say huge amounts a lot more
than this 90 million that we're reading
here so anyway I'm hoping that can be
included Senator Bentley yeah I you know
I'm just sort of thinking about scope
and what is actually doable and I think
you know what I'm hearing is your desire
to sort of expand it to look at you know
what's happening at the Lea level and I
think you know while that would be
valuable information that would be
impossible to do to look at every Lea
and so what I think that this committee
needs to sort of focus on is the scope
of you know this audit is supposed to
look at the department of education's
um
efficiency or you know ability to to
conduct their monitoring enforcement of
you know these requirements right we're
looking at the department you know are
there policy the appropriate policies in
place to adequately meet their
monitoring and enforcement requirements
like so I think that has to be that has
to be sort of the focus here because
they are you know there's very
prescriptive requirements for monitoring
and enforcement within federal law and
state law and I think that that needs to
remain the focus because I think whether
the um leas are appropriately spending
money and how much sort of flows from
that so I think it's more appropriate to
look within the department rather than
going to the leas and you know if if
you're doing your job the way that it's
required in federal law they I think the
Auditors will be able to see you know
whether that that the leas are acting
appropriately so if I just might respond
I mean so I was not advocating that we
audit all of the leas but in auditing we
have a an approach called Sam length
right so it is possible to sample leas
and understand better what is happening
in that sample of leas that's I guess
what I'm saying relative to the scope is
that it really I think you're missing
something if you don't go beyond it's a
little bit like the dispute resolution
like we're we've we've made a selection
of transactions to audit but we sampled
out of 10 of the transactions rather
than the whole pie of transactions and
we're going to reach a conclusion about
a population of transactions when we've
only looked at a subset you're going to
run into the same problem I believe here
in terms of trying to reach conclusions
about what's happening with where the
bulk of the performance is taking place
you'll try to reach conclusions and you
will have only looked at a very narrow
subset of what's actually happening
[Music]
is that if
Hartman is doing its job in terms of
fulfilling those requirements that
sampling wouldn't be necessary because
it would already be in the review of
what you are doing in your department so
I think that's already done
there are questions
represented thanks Senator do you have
specific recommendations you can provide
the committee in terms of how you would
see extending the
the scope we have here so we're happy to
work with the lva in terms of trying to
design a scope that includes a both and
as opposed to a singular approach those
were conversations that we did have with
the
um the uh LBA prior to this
um and I'm happy to engage in those
conversations with them so we're using
jaywood
number of districts
to see the interaction of the department
and the local school district and
relative to the performance in the local
school district in terms of meeting
again there's this body of you know
regulatory
um
you know uh schema that is you know
required to be complied with and again
we have a role in that performance and
the Lea has a role in that performance
and is really a both end
but we wouldn't be
looking to do a performance on it of the
leas because
we
can't why can't well we can really do is
look at did the department do meat its
regulation requirements
in how it interacted
with leas and so and I was at Point
Senator Whitley was trying to bring up
right that if you're meeting those
requirements then why would we sample
and that's in fact what the fiscal
committee approved was
to conduct a performance audit of the
efficiency and effectiveness of the
Department of education's oversight of
the provision of so so I think you would
it would seem to me that if we would
broaden the scope we would have to go
back to the fiscal committee because
they were pretty prescriptive in their
approval
any other questions
I just have a a comment that kind of
meshes I think with Senator Whitley's
which is
uh coming from small rural communities
rather than large urban communities I
think in order to have any kind of
Representative sampling
of how we're doing on the local level
we would need a lot more time and a lot
more Personnel than we have available to
us
uh before we could actually get a
representative sampling of school
districts
because as we all know uh the Manchester
and Nashua districts are nothing like
the Fall Mountain School District
representative Griffin commissioner how
does your department uh
uh address that issue now do you have
people who actually go out and look at
the local operations we do do some
monitoring for the various districts it
is somewhat of a paper tiger in terms of
there's a lot of limitations on what we
can say what we can lean in on and even
we suffer from the we have no access to
these mediated settlements that take
place in the district so if there is an
issue and and a district decides to
settle that locally then that's out of
our hands and we don't see any kind of
an infraction so even if I'm monitoring
a district I'm not going to see that and
so I may I myself May reach an incorrect
conclusion in that process wouldn't that
be part of the dispute resolution as if
it gets to a dispute resolution okay but
that's the point is these are taking
place these happen these are settle long
before they get into that process so
again we're we're looking at a subset of
what state in place and reaching a
conclusion about the totality of it
which may be what was the the parents
who came to this committee and expressed
their concerns and the fiscal committee
Express their concerns are trying to say
like hey over here you're not hearing us
right and so I think that the objective
of this audit in my recollection of
sitting through those committee hearings
I think you were I think you were part
of that right there was a lot of concern
about you know how these um these things
are being handled in the field
thank you madam chair I think for for Mr
Henry Mr Grady
to make a full-rounded report have a few
tables showing things like the the
formula three and a half times ten times
eighty percent so on and what I haven't
seen in quite a while is the very
numerous list of what an IEP is for I
mean I remember being seeing things like
anxiety which may or may not affect the
real academic achievement and and they
keep adding new things and I've been a
while since I've really seen a list do
you have any idea how many there are
there could be a hundred I do we have a
very discreet list of diagnoses yeah but
it's it's very extensive it's just been
so long since I've seen a complete list
and I think to have a rounded report at
least show the list even though you
didn't don't have to go down and and
cover each one but there's some of them
that that seem a little strange to even
even be included in an IEP thank you and
I appreciate you letting me come in and
share my concerns about the scope
a question
um if the goals are to further education
employment and independent living those
last two seem almost
retrospective like you wouldn't really
know until the end of someone's
High School career yeah well really all
of them whether they were furthering
their education whether they were
employed or living independently and
those actions might take some
transition and time so get some curious
for the lva how would you measure
those
three
goals
manager Steve Brady again
um coming up Steve
I guess
it'll work
so in IEP planning at the age of 14
years IEP teams are supposed to plan uh
students transition it is supposed to
include whatever objectives that
individual has in mind so whether it's
further education
employment and then an underlying
Independent Living so starting at the
age of 14 IEP should be moving a student
towards those goals
um and yes they transition out of the
program in any number of ways some may
drop out some may graduate some may then
go into subsequent education settings
they may go get a job afterwards they
and hopefully are getting uh moving
towards independent living
there is a survey that the department
does of post
program exiting students that measures
both education and employment in some
respects there are some methodological
concerns with respect to that survey and
only gets to I think we were told maybe
two percent of the population and there
are a number of mechanical problems with
getting the survey to everybody that we
would like to see get that survey and it
is done once uh one year after they
leave the program and then
never again so systematically
it is something that is of a concern but
we do have procedural control concerns
around that so you're you're audit would
look at
how the survey was administered how many
people responded
okay we expect to look at the life cycle
of a student's engagement with the
special education program so we expect
to pick that up somewhere around the age
of 14 look at the transition see what's
monitored with respect to transition
planning on the state level at the state
level yep because every every
jurisdiction most jurisdictions report
dated at the state if the state's
collecting those data we'll look at it
if the state's not collecting relevant
data we'll have something to say about
it and suggest that they actually
collect those types of data
Madam chair I think it might benefit the
as we're talking about the scope I think
that this committee would benefit from
looking at the federal requirements of
the sca the Department of Education
because
Ida which is the federal you know
special ed law place is pretty strict
requirements or responsibilities for
monitoring and enforcement of the local
communities places that with the
Department of Education and so if I
think we it would help us understand
what the doe may already have in their
possession in terms of monitoring leas
if we saw that those requirements that
would be a suggestion of mine is that
something Nick you could provide us yeah
I assume that that would already be part
of the scope of this audit
commissioner this I'm new to the board
here and I'm just trying to make sure
I'm understanding what you're asking is
I'm reading the audit scope as you know
how effective was the Department's
General supervision of the state's
special education program in producing
expected outcomes and from what I'm
understanding you're saying is this is
more of a partnership with you and the
districts themselves in achieving those
expected outcomes and it seems that
you're asking for a little bit more
depth in the scope here to make sure
that you're achieving those expected
outcomes and you don't feel that we have
quite enough in here to really gauge
that I worry that when we scope these
audits we scope them such that we're not
actually answering the the Salient
question which is the customer that's
being served and so we have a sampling
of convenience because this is what we
can cover my objective was none other
today was none other than to come in and
share with you my concerns about the
scope but assuming that the audit would
be conduct you know be going forward
um you know as an example you know what
relative to the scope statement when we
first got the scope statement relative
to those goals it said you know to make
sure that all these students had
post-secondary and would say well that's
not really the goal for these kids so we
expanded it working with the LBA to say
like no there's much broader goals for
these students right so again just you
know because if we I mean initially a
scope statement said to make sure that
every student is prepared for
post-secondary well some of these kids
are not going to do post-secondary and
that's not even the best pathway for
them so I want to make sure we don't
have kind of a a scope statement of
convenience because if that was your
scope statement and they came back and
said well the eight percent of the kids
went to post-secondary well that wasn't
even the goal for these kids right so we
have to make sure we get a scope
statement that answers the question that
the families of New Hampshire are asking
you know that's what I'm after a while
yeah one of the things that that I think
is is a success in special ed and it's a
note that I've seen through the years as
far more special ed in elementary
schools than there is in the later
grades and it's all due to not learning
to read
and so once that student gets gets uh
IEP for reading
and they really learned to read which
they maybe didn't learn in the first few
grades then suddenly they're a regular
student and it's the success of the
program we want all our kids reading yes
we wish they were all that easy yeah
Senator Lang thank you and I apologize
for missing some of the meetings of this
got asked I apologize I'm asking it
again so I I like said on the Pearl I am
concerned about that producing expected
outcomes statement in line
um because it's as I read this it seems
like it's related to the top part of the
page it talks about
um the department functioned as a pass
through entity for federal grants that
made through sub grants the local ages
it had to and it has about eight or ten
bullet points there that are basically
about the management of the federal
grants but doesn't talk about the
individual student right it doesn't have
the outcomes about the individual
student so I'm trying to understand is
this audit scope about the fact that
you've managed the money properly you've
done the Performance Management right
you've issued you've done everything but
you can't get down to the bottom detail
date of the student and the outcomes of
the student which so that word outcomes
is I guess my question what are we
measuring here as we look at this we're
looking at how the agency has managed
special education dollars and did it
make its way down given the leas saying
this is what we're doing right and
you've audited that because one of the
things in here is monitor the operations
of local agencies and it's a test to see
are you in fact monitoring but again it
doesn't get down to student outcomes
it's about the outcomes of the dollars
and the management of the dollars and
the management of getting it to the
students again I just I worry having sat
through some of the meetings relative to
the scoping of this audit and the
conversations with Senator Reagan and
the conversations with the families that
were coming in
the goal was that we had families who
didn't believe that their interests were
being served by a bureaucracy and so I
don't want to go say like well the
bureaucracy did everything it was
responsible for if the students haven't
been served so representative
well I think
the even larger sampling that we're
ignoring in that question
is all the families who aren't
complaining and who feel that they have
been well served
so there's that
um
I'm wondering first of all sometimes
when we have these meetings
suddenly a number of audits have wrapped
up and you're looking immediately for
more work
my first question is is it am I correct
in sensing that you have plenty of work
to be going on with at this point with
respect to this audit no I I mean with
respect to the other other audits that
are going on to defer to somebody else
but I I've been working on this
particular subject since November of
2022 in order to prepare this statement
and you you so I'm gathering that your
perspective as you'd like to proceed
forward with all deliberate speak I
would like to proceed forward with
whatever's going to satisfy this
committee's questions okay I need to do
something different I would
I I was trying to figure out whether we
have some time to
think about all the new things that have
been brought up because this is a very
different group of people than the ones
who approved the statement
um and while I don't want to slow
anybody down I don't want to rush it
either so I'm trying to figure out uh in
the context of what we can do today
um
whether what we really want to do is
Full Speed Ahead and I'm I'm actually
relatively comfortable with that but but
willing to be persuaded otherwise
because my
my perception is that what we were
talking about
was
looking most specifically about how the
department
interacts
with those it's supervising
and we were not planning nor I think can
we appropriately with the staff we have
unless we want to employ a lot of other
Auditors
make any kind of a comprehensive
evaluation of how individual students
needs are being met and the percentage
of students whose needs are being met so
I I was comfortable with the scope as we
approved it I'm still comfortable but if
there are tweaks that the committee
wants to suggest
I'm certainly willing to listen to them
Senator Whitley uh Madam chair I'm also
comfortable with a scope and that's only
because I know that federal law is is
very specific that they place the
responsibility of monitoring and
enforcement of our leas on the doe and
so what what I think the committee is
interested in should be already
available if the Dewey is appropriately
doing their monitoring as required by
federal law so that's why I think this
scope is appropriate because it should
already be there representative
thank you madam chair
so I have a very different perception
um having been with the committee when
the prior chairman who was the one that
was requesting this uh
was speaking to it and it much more
closely matches what we're hearing from
the commissioner and that is what are
the results why are why was he getting
all these complaints regarding special
education specifically from parents
related to their children
I understand the issue of trying to get
to all of the children would be a very
big problem but during the presentation
that the LBA gave here
they specifically stated that these
performance audits relate to past
performance analysis
and that users can be included in the
in the analysis
so it certainly would seem reasonable to
me in fact I would expect it that they
would be talking to these
but the parents and the children
how have they perceived proceed and how
the outcomes continued past I don't know
what whether I say high school or
whatever I say but beyond this period of
time we're talking about what about the
kids that are the folks that have been
filed for five years where are they in
terms of this life cycle and where are
the parents or caregivers and how are
they seeing the process and has it
gotten better or worse or whatever so I
would very much like to see that at
least at some level that we would hear
more than just I'm sure they want to
know that the department is doing
everything correct per federal law but I
sat on the finance committee on our town
and I was on the school board part of it
and the biggest black hole
is with special education and I do
believe that it would be helpful if we
started to dig into it at the whole
level not just are we obeying the
federal law especially the federal law
uh you can obey the federal law as it
was sort of implied here and still not
get any good results out of the other
end
I appreciate that clarification and what
really thank you madam chair and what I
was saying is that you know I fully
agree with you and I think that
information is very valuable but I guess
my point was if the department was doing
like complying with Federal requirements
about monitoring they should have
already looked into those parents
complaints and looked into those budgets
that didn't work so I'm saying that the
information should already be there if
they're doing their work appropriately
I guess where I'm struggling on the
scope statement is with the two words in
producing
because the department can only do
its part the local districts have to do
their parts
and the federal government has to do its
part so for me
the words in producing is it's giving I
think the department more power than it
actually has so I'm not sure those two
words are right representative Weber
I'm just reading what what you're going
to do with this and it seems to me that
a great deal of what I think I'm hearing
representative say are included under
the bullet points on page three of
obtain perspective from stakeholders
outside the department
and observe board and Sac meetings
do those not
speak to
sort of the end the end results and also
um the the work done the incorporation
of the work done by the committee to
study special education dispute
resolution options
uh
do those not help us get
towards including in this the kinds of
interactions that representative erf is
talking about I believe they do
they do created to advise the
commissioner on special education it is
also specifically composed of parents it
is supposed to be a forum for airing
concerns that Gap that the commissioner
has referenced of things that don't
manifest themselves in the Department's
radar those kinds of things should flow
through the state advisory committee if
the state advisory committee is working
correctly and providing the input that
it needs to
then the department should be well
informed as to the concerns that the
program may be facing if that committee
is not working well then we have a
systemic defect because that committee
can contribute to not just one or two or
a handful of students or local
educations efficiency and Effectiveness
but to the systems efficiency and
Effectiveness affecting 175 local
jurisdictions and 31 000 students and
that's the locus of control in this
relationship that the federal government
has with the state and the locals
everything flows through the department
and to have 90 million dollars budgeted
at the state and to suggest that 900
million dollars is the real number we
should be looking at
is a little bit misleading because that
90 million dollars or that seven and a
half million dollars that's budgeted for
Department operations controls
the results of that 900 million dollars
and that's why we've chosen to scope
this audit the way it has because it's
going to have the broadest effect that
it possibly can because we cannot audit
175 localities we have statutory
prohibitions on the number of localities
we can actually look at in any amount of
time
moreover we cannot individually review
31 000 IEPs we can't even take a sample
of 31 000 IEPs and do that in any time
that's practical so to hopefully address
some of your concerns we have targeted
targeted this audit to focus and the key
State control and that is the department
and its operation of the program
but
it might be an over and overstatement
produce
those extra outcomes and that's where
I'm struggling on this well and the
department is sorry the department is
obligated to take a look at the data
that he gets back and produce empirical
results from the data that it's
collecting from the jurisdictions to
identify successful and unsuccessful
approaches so if the department is doing
that correctly it should be identifying
good approaches at transition planning
for 14 through 21 year 22 year olds if
it's not collecting data on that then
that's a gap in the control framework if
it's not what we're seeing that
performance well then that's another Gap
in the control framework so that's again
that's why we're we're targeting it
where we're targeting it
Senator Lang so again I I guess I'm okay
with this going forward just with the
understanding that we're actually just
auditing department and not the
educational outcomes right there's no
educational component of this at all
alls are doing is whether or not the
Department's checked all the boxes the
way it's supposed to check all of the
boxes and my one concern would be that
we tell the audit comes out and says hey
they're doing their job and we have
parents screaming like no they're not
and it seems like a completely
contrasting discussion when we're saying
we're going to audit them and the audit
says they're doing their job and we have
parents but I will say that and I guess
it's a matter of timing on whether or
not you have the special education
dispute resolution process audit that's
due out in in a few months on whether
this should be held until we know what
that looks like to see what the scope
should look like because that that
addresses the parents question right
there whereas this is just addressing
the business question
this scope addresses more than the
business question it is not a compliance
audit we do compliance auditing within
the context of a performance audit but
we're looking for results so we're going
to be looking at the effectiveness of
the Department's compliance or
non-compliance with the requirements
that are imposed applying and if those
do not produce the results that we are
looking for from the program which is
articulated in state law we're looking
to ensure that students have an
opportunity to get into subsequent
education to get into employment and to
achieve Independent Living if they're
not contributing to those results that
that's the focus of the audit does does
the system the department has in place
contribute to achieving those expected
outcomes that the legislature has
imposed upon it in RSA 186c it seems
like that word contribute to
is important Senator Whitley yeah and I
sort of feel like a broken record about
this but just to follow up on what you
just said the the department is required
to make sure that the leas are achieving
those outcomes and so that's what we're
looking for so I think it's Senator Lang
you're right that it's both you know are
they Meeting those requirements but then
to to
um to know if they meet those
requirements they have to look at the
outcomes so that's that was sort of my
point is that correct it is and one of
the results that federal law and Rule
expects is improved results for students
and that is one of the things we're
going to be looking at is there a
mechanism in place to examine whether
results improved over time or did not
improve over time if there's no system
in place for that then that's a systemic
law in the Department's control
construct and then we'll look at the
data to see whether there's actual
Improvement demonstrated or not and then
we'll go from there to see what might be
contributing to what we're seeing in the
data so if you were to expand this scope
it wouldn't take longer
it would definitely take longer I was
asked to calculate those numbers at a
minimum it would take four extra months
and another quarter million dollars
okay
what is the committee's pleasure
representative or
so just one other question there Senator
Whitley has made pretty clear that the
federal laws
you know dictating on this one and I
totally get that
do you envision that in your audit
you might perceive weaknesses in what
the federal law allows the state to do
in terms of
uh
overseeing the local localities so we
might become aware of the fact that
there are areas there where the state is
incapable of
totally overseeing the uh localities if
we found something like that we would
certainly have something to say I will
note that the federal regulatory
construct gives the department a great
deal of discretion in how it implements
the program at the state level
so it is not it's not a checklist per se
that the state just picks up and runs
with the federal government places a
significant amount of requirements upon
the expenditures of funds and the like
but it does not specify how the
department is going to frame the program
how it's going to achieve improved
results for students how it's going to
ensure that the results at the state
because it's still fundamentally a state
program it is federally subsidized to
some extent but it is still
fundamentally a state program
so the federal government delegates
substantial amount of authority to the
department to construct a program to
effectively achieve those expected
outcomes so can I just comment I just I
just want to end can I get to that yes
of course where does enforcement come in
that enforcement comes with the back end
the department has an obligation to
identify aberrant performance in the
program and to address it through
enforcement mechanisms if necessary
so those entities that are
persistently non-compliant are subject
to sanctions to include up to including
suspension of their Grant
so can I just clarify I mean because I
think it's an overstatement to say that
the department has significant amount of
latitude to enforce this I mean I am
regularly hemmed in by my own agency
saying you don't have authority to go
there like all I can do is work within a
procedural framework and I use as an
example this recent example of uh you
know a poorly executed IEP and a student
clearly everybody's intention was for a
child to be able to get this experience
this year and the district not doing
that and I don't have the ability I have
no no legal authority to come in and say
like look give the people the thing what
we do is we work with schools you know
with our relationships to try and help
them to do the best thing for the child
but that would be an example of not
having the authority I would have been
happy to order put the kid in IP today
but I didn't have that Authority could
we give you that Authority I don't know
the answer to that and isn't that why
we're thinking about proceeding with
this performance audit right would you
be willing to entertain emotion
well are there more questions or is the
committee
will to
okay I'm willing to entertain emotion
I would move that we accept the scope
statement as written taking into account
the explanations about all of the
aspects that members of the committee
have touched on that appear to me to be
part of what the audit is going to look
at
I'm good with that as long as the LBA is
good with that that they've been taking
copious notes and um they'll take that
into consideration when they're actually
doing the auditing work
if you'd like me to respond I certain we
will be so
fiscal descriptions yes we're going to
take a look at Trend data over time or
can we include such a table as to what
our IEP suitable conditions for students
we can certainly include that kind of
material in there and if there are other
specific concerns we can address those
as well and yes we'll go back through
our notes and make sure we've got
everything but fundamentally I just want
to state that what we've discussed here
today principally is what was in the
scope we intend to take a look at the
results the department is facilitating
through the state system and see whether
it achieves those expected results or
not and given its limitations and we'll
take one closely look at what the
provisions of federal law and state law
provide as well as Federal rules State
rules and other authoritative guidance
and we will identify any gaps and if
there are opportunities for this body to
suggest legislation or to for
legislation here to be suggested we'll
certainly identify those as well Senator
thank you madam chair and I think it
would be helpful Mr Grady if you would
share I think it would it would um you
know make the committee perhaps more
comfortable with the scope if you could
forward us those Federal requirements
regarding monitor enforcement because I
think that's relevant to our
conversation if you're able to send them
on do that it might take a little bit of
touch because we're just scoping now
right
statements field work with and that is
something that we would work through
during field work but it is certainly
something that we could generate for
this body as soon as we recently can we
can certainly prioritize that part of
our plan work uh to occur sooner rather
than later and get you those citations
that would be great there are more
discussion okay so the motion is to
approve this scope
and the audit committee has been taking
notes in our discussion and
um any
other all right I think we can do a
Voice vote
if you're in favor of the motion please
say aye
aye
any opposition
okay the scope is approved thank you
thank you and thank you commissioner
that was a good fulsome discussion
um
okay what else do we need to talk about
now
the table then suspended items yep just
just very quickly on item number four
there in terms of the um suspended or or
table topics just a
little
brief synopsis uh the Bureau of elderly
and Adult Services
that was suspended November 21 by this
committee largely because
when we began the audit we became aware
of to to legal proceedings lawsuits that
were going to be Central to the
autotopic
so so as not to interfere with that or
have that interfere with our audit we
the committee recommended that we we
suspend that for and whatever teams are
still on yeah yeah and probably will be
for a while is my guess
uh Public Access and bodies of water I
think as I recall discussion amongst the
committee there was going to be some
other legislative subcommittee that was
going to be looking into some of that so
it was decided not to move forward with
that at that point in time what's there
does anybody know
s
your apartment did I get that right yeah
and Senator Pearl's not here so what I
think if I remember correctly with uh
those I I think you had someone had
asked you about public access to water
you brought it up as a topic that you
received and it was just sort of the
topic and at the meeting I believe
Senator guy to said oh I'm on a
committee that looks at that issue
and then but nothing happened like no we
didn't vote you didn't vote on whether
to kill the topic or to accept the topic
it was more it was just still there so
we kept it on the books for
for you to decide
anybody
represented the Weber I think I raised
it at the request of a former
representative now that my memory is
being jogged and as I have heard nothing
further in this direction it may be one
that we want to leave for a little while
to see if anybody comes up with
something but
um if not
I'm comfortable going either way with it
okay
what about the Secretary of State's
archives and Records yeah that one is we
we do have a uh a limitation that we
cannot from performance out of
perspective go into a stat uh
constitutional
officer like Secretary of State's office
in his duties so I think that that was
the reason that we table that or you
can't at this point in time
that office
correct yeah there's uh in our statute
it says that we're not allowed to audit
the I think the Constitutional duties of
a constitutional officer and so you've
got I believe the Attorney General the
treasurer
and
well secretary of state right those are
three constitutional officers and we're
unclear if we can audit anything they do
if everything in their agency is
considered a constitutional Duty which
isn't which isn't um you know written
out in no one's defined what
constitutional Duties are at least we
haven't found it and we had Senate
research do some work for us and it's a
little vague so and why we can't look at
those offices as another one of these
questions of it goes way back to the
beginning of this this committee back in
like 87
um it seems like it was a holdover from
there was a sunset review commission
that was in place before they they
created performance Audits and there
were certain
agencies that the sunset Review
Committee couldn't look at including
Corrections and the Constitutional
officers so I think I think it was a
holdover
from that but you know why we can't now
I'm not sure representative whoever
well if if we can't now because of
Statute and I think you probably
provided us with a statutory reference
but perhaps you could do that again
because it seems to me that there's a
difference between
uh what we are prohibited to do by
Statute because we could simply change
the statute should we choose to audit
those uh branches of government if there
is a constitutional prohibition that
though uh that that is something we
can't stray into but it sounds from what
you're saying that it's more of a
statutory prohibition than a
constitutional one and I
I think from my perspective
unless there is a constitutional
separation of powers issue which doesn't
seem to me like there can be because
what we do is audit the executive branch
all the time and and we're the
legislature and we've always been told
that the Secretary of State's office
sort of occupies a unique Niche between
those two
it would seem to me that one of the
things we could consider is legislative
action
on the statute
because it does seem to me that the
Constitutional offices
have an enormous amount of effect on on
our government and our citizens and if
if nobody's kind of
overseeing that it's perhaps an issue
also
the number of different things those
agencies are doing at this point in time
is enormous so I I think that's
something for the committee to think
about for members to discuss among
themselves but I also want to say that
I'm I'm really very pleased at the
thoughtfulness and quality of the debate
that we've had here today because we've
spent a number of years coming in and
saying yeah we'll do that bang and
leaving and I think these are things we
really ought to think a little bit
harder about so thank you for bringing
that up
it was chaired by Senator Reagan we
budge oh got it
okay budget
archives and records and I mean line
items in the budget we know it's not
like the judicial branch where we just
give them money and say here goes Bandit
so yeah if I may it's RSA 14 colon 31a
letter D where it states uh this is the
LBA audit division statute
um letter D is conduct such program
result audits of any Department board
institution Etc however further in the
in the middle of the uh the section says
this paragraph shall not apply to
constitutional officers in the execution
of their constitutional duties
so that's the limitation that we're
referring to
there may be one the only reason I can
think of is we don't audit the
legislature because that would be a
conflict you're our boss and so we we
audit everyone else I believe the
legislature has a role in picking those
positions and whether that's in some way
considered
you know you're picking that person in a
legislative role and then should we go
in there and audit them that may be
maybe the reason but that's just a guess
on my part so if we wanted if we were
hearing for example that
on all the papers in the archives have
water dripping on them and they were
getting mildewed we couldn't
audit how
the secretary of state was
handling the records of the state I
think it's it's questionable someone I
mean we'd have to seek legal advice on
whether you could send us in now
could you hire an outside consultant to
come in and do that
probably which is kind you know which is
kind of strange
but whether you could send us in to look
at that is is questionable
okay Madam chair yes
thank you I I will volunteer uh for the
committee to
um you know work with Senate research to
see if we can get more legislative
history on the provision that they just
mentioned that would be great that would
be helpful
great
put the lawyers on it the last topic
there is oblc oplc just a little history
on that um there was a lot of discussion
amongst previous committees
um obviously there's been a lot of
restructuring going on with oplc a lot
of
transition and turnover and positions
and things of that nature but the but
the LBA also made them aware that there
has been several recent audits that have
touched on elements of oplc in
particular the the most recent Board of
dental examiners there was a very large
section there that dealt with oplc's
control structure environment and there
will be some elements as well coming out
in the mental health Workforce
requirements audit because you're
dealing with several boards there too so
so given given the work that we were
doing the committee decided just a table
of full-blown audit of oplc itself so
that's a little history with that one so
okay so does anybody wish to take any of
these days hold on it's
off the table
yeah exactly
uh representative Weber with reset
respect the office of professional
licensure
um that's absolutely true that there
have been little bits of it looked at
um having sat on this committee
continuously the longest it seems to me
that every year we say we ought to do
something about that and they're still
restructuring and they have been
restructured uh continuously for as long
as I have served in this body uh so at
some point we might want to think about
um
a look at the current structure and
seeing because
many of the things that are recommended
during an audit are actually very
helpful to an agency in their operations
and it's a fresh pair of eyes a
different perspective and uh sometimes
quite useful either either for the
agency or for us or for both
depending on everybody's mindset going
in and coming out
um so I I definitely don't want to take
this one off the list but I'd certainly
agree that this isn't the time to
launch into something else and we may
decide to do it in within the scope of
those bytes of particular professions
that we have done
so thank you yeah I agree I shouldn't
come off I mean I know the house passed
a 78 page about the restructuring of
oplc and I know I put a couple bills in
about oplc
we change the funding sources and a
bunch of things so I agree while it
might need something we first have to
get into a stable place before we can
audit anything
any other business us that any members
want to bring forward
okay
um
well I don't see this is a public
meeting it is not a public hearing so it
would be up to
the folks here for two minutes
two minutes Mr Huss
okay one and a half minutes because I
have been meeting at 10 45.
two minutes
two comments I want to make on the
commission of human rights to the office
of professional convention
from Gilman
uh just uh one and a half minutes here
okay uh on the commission of Human
Rights and also the office of
professional licensure and certification
my comment is that I did attend the uh
house bill I don't know the number on
human rights at the house Judiciary
Committee and Ani ahni the black woman
in charge of the human rights came in
and she gave an excellent presentation
saying that there's 230 cases there
sitting and they have four five
investigators four that actually have a
case load of 25 each
the other one handles the back load
and she asked for three more
investigators and she got two according
to the budget
not last I heard
and uh
also too the number of hearings they
have per year is less than one there's
four hearings in five years time
and so I make a comparison to the office
of professional that there's a
subdivision of that that's the real
estate commission so I would like if you
could to reopen to have another vote
maybe to have an investigation of that
because I've asked Lindsay Courtney is
the chair is the commissioner
she sent me an email the other day
because I got the Royal run around from
the underlings and the underlings all
they say is contact the right to know if
you have a problem so I contacted Thomas
Kerr kehr at the State House Annex
that's where I'm going next
and uh the
I'm trying to get a comparison like what
I just told you on the human rights how
many cases do they have of complaints
that the Real Estate Commission I can't
get an answer of that
I mean right to know I can go and like
get a whole year Supply and do my own
statistics but I'm trying to find out
how how long a time does it take to have
a complaint process there I filed one
last June it's still sitting there 10
months has gone by ridiculous how many
investigators they have they have one
investigator they have one paralegal
that's it I don't know what the other
details but it would be nice to have you
all investigate thank you thank you
thank you very much so the date of the
next meeting you guys will tell us
right
yes okay officially it's at your call
yes but
I'm not gonna it's not a meeting until I
hear from we will reach out to you madam
chair when when we we need another
meeting but certainly if the committee
wants to right
yeah
so thank you all very much there being
no further business we'll adjourn
thank you